this is the story from the new york
times suspect in capital attack appears
to have been a follower of louis
farrakhan for those that aren't familiar
he is
the leader of the nation of islam who
has repeatedly promoted anti-semitism
the suspect noah r green 25 was
identified by two law enforcement
officials
and a congressional official he was from
indiana and died of being shot by
capitol police
on facebook mr green had posted speeches
and articles written by mr farrakhan
and elijah muhammad who led the nation
of islam from 1934 to 1975
that discussed the decline of america
two law enforcement officials confirmed
that the facebook page which was taken
down on friday had belonged to
mr green mr green posted on facebook
about his personal struggles
especially during the pandemic quote to
be honest these past few years have been
tough
and these past few months have been
tougher i have been tried with some of
the biggest unimaginable tests of my
life
i am currently now unemployed and i left
my job partly due to afflictions
he also spoke on facebook about the end
times and the antichrist on march 17th
he posted a photo of a donation he made
to the norfolk virginia chapter of the
nation of islam
along with a video of farrakhan's speech
entitled the divine destruction of
america
later that day he encouraged his friends
to join him in studying the teachings of
fair khan and mr muhammad the nation of
islam is a black nationalist movement
that has advocated african-american
self-sufficiency all right i've got i've
got a thread pulled up from andy noe
who's dug in a little bit to who this
guy is and some of the things he said
and i want to point out something the
way the new york times is
quoting this guy as if we're going to
look at his statements
not that long ago it was a police
officer who was paraphrasing
what a mass shooter had said and he
lost his job basically for this he was
attacked they accused him of placating
this this
evil man why is the new york times
what's with the double standard we get
it though we see the double standard all
the time
the mainstream establishment corporate
press and politicians are deferential to
left-wing extremism
they would come out with in in seconds
condemning this and saying everything
you'd expect them to say terror
ban guns all that stuff if this actually
was a white person
as we've often seen this time though
many of these people did come out they
did say that
now they're going to become very quiet
that we're learning now that we're
learning who the suspect is
that's exactly what happened with uh
with boulder
in fact now andy no posts about the the
suspect here and i just want to point
out uh one of
a couple other things he says in his
last instagram post before the attack he
wrote
the us government is the number one
enemy of black people we are very much
seeing leftist identitarianism and it's
reaching
extreme levels when it comes to antifa
and black lives matter we've long seen
what i refer to as like blunt force
extremism in that the attacks they
engaged in
weren't the the most violent most
violent or most lethal
but they were consistent and there were
several instances of them so when when
these riots start and they burn down
buildings they cause massive destruction
the loss of life is extensive across the
country
but the media as i mentioned deferential
when it comes to
these these mass shooters these are high
profile very acute instances
where everyone's attention is is just
grabbed instantly
so when you're dealing with endless
anti-fun black lives matter violence
but the on average you know they're
punching people and they're beating
people that stuff doesn't become
national news
now as things become hyper-polarized
this may be a one-off and hopefully this
is just some
some sick man and that's the end of it
but it may be
that things are going to get even worse
from this i know maybe it's a bit
pessimistic for me to say
but i can already see the demands that
we ban guns over this
that we reinstate security around the
capitol lock it down send to the
national guard
now a lot of these people were saying
this before they realized this shooter
was actually a black nationalist
but we have this tweet from rep elaine
omar she said the death toll would have
been worse if the assailant had an ar-15
instead of a knife
just completely unrelated to what
happened but there's
already efforts for many people to
weaponize this
so i don't know what you guys think it's
it's always hard to kind of segue into a
conversation we're dealing with such
serious
uh news topics and you know kind of this
hyperpolarization but
i suppose considering you know we've all
talked about this i'm curious your
thoughts julie on
the hyperpolarization the conflict the
security state and you know everything's
been going on
sure i think there's absolutely a double
standard you know a few weeks ago when
that guy who happened to be white
shot up the atlanta spas people
automatically said oh this is a white
supremacist terrorist
maybe we don't know but they were quick
to jump on that
we don't really know his intentions
maybe he was a sex addict we don't know
if he was asian or not asian
if it's just like him going after these
women for
being women and tempting him we don't
know but as soon as he did it it was
like white supremacist
terrorist but now this guy who
is we know is a nation of islam which is
a black supremacist
very racist group like everyone thinks
they're racist that's not a
controversial thing
this guy went to the capitol with a
knife he killed a police officer
and they're saying oh there's no
terrorism there's no we
see no evidence of terrorism like it's
been a few
hours people like what did you have to
investigate that
spend a few minutes maybe yeah they're
just oh he was islam
he was the nation of islam guys so
therefore it's not terrorism we don't
want to like offend people you know we
don't want to
say you know make people uncomfortable
it's like
it's the future you know what's
interesting is uh when when that
when that tragedy happened in atlanta
the i believe it was the police i'm not
sure they said it wasn't race related
right so here's what i find interesting
they came out and said no no it wasn't
he was a sex addict
two of the victims were white but even
you point out we we don't really know
we need an investigation a lot of people
on the left immediately said it was a
race thing even when
when the police come out and say it's
not now i know
uh well maybe it's a bit unfair for me
to say this but i'll speculate and i'd
be willing to bet on this
the left is immediately going to change
their tune and say it was it terror it
was a disturbed young man and that's the
game they'll play
unless they want to ban guns you know i
i think it's it's ridiculous that ilhan
omar was like what if he had a gun
what if he had a tank i don't know it's
ridiculous is this is a tragedy
you can speculate whatever you want but
they're gonna they're gonna do it
because
it's an excuse to gain power absolutely
but he had a knife
he brought a knife to a gunfight he got
killed that was dumb
it was a poor strategy could it be
suicide by cop it's possible did he ram
he rammed somebody with his car
is that right i guess he rammed through
the barricade yeah
yeah yeah so he's the car and a knife
yeah yeah yeah you know what gets me
about this this georgia thing is with
georgia is that where he the guy
murdered
six in this in the spas yeah like
they'll do
if they're gonna do like tests or like
investigations and then in a year and a
month they're like
okay we figured out he was racist we
figured out
he wasn't racist like what difference
does it make that guy
murdered six people he was deranged
eight people i think
eight people yeah it's yeah it was
terrifying you want to call it terror
or not terror it it was terrifying for
those people
it may be maybe it wasn't political
terror what's the difference man
this is i i agree it's like hate crimes
right
where they're like we're gonna we're
gonna investigate your your thought
process before you committed a crime
it's like dude hitting someone's illegal
like the reason why you did it you did
it you know what i mean the action is
illegal
i can't read your mind and they try to
infer
as to as to what you were thinking one
of the biggest reasons i have a problem
with terror laws
and hate crime laws is that they're
going to be selectively used
in this instance it's already saying it
wasn't terror well dude was a black
nationalist who posted on instagram that
the american government is the enemy of
black people
what's are you kidding me and they're
going to be like no look i don't care if
they do or don't just keep
it consistent i think this guy committed
a crime that's enough
let me see if i got this straight so
this guy was on facebook and instagram
posting about how much he hated the us
government
and then he went to washington dc and
rammed into the capital fence
and they're calling this definitely not
terrorism
that's an act of politics is that what
i'm yeah it is an act of political
terror
i'm not i don't support these like
terror laws where you throw people in
gitmo because of the way they were
thinking when they did the crime
right he's from indiana he went to dc
was he in dc for was he in school
i don't know yeah making a political
statement yes
maybe why would you go to dc that's a
good point lydia yeah that's what i was
thinking so glenn glenn greenwald called
this out we have this post from politico
the suspect was not known to capitol
police or dc police officials said
robert conti the acting d.c police chief
said the incident does not appear to be
terrorism-related and there was no
indication of a nexus to a member of
congress
glenn greenwald responded on what basis
did the police pronounce the capital
attack does not appear to be terror
uh terrorism related how was it remotely
possible to determine the mode of the
attacker
this early which by the way is what
determines whether an act of violence is
or is not terror
politics it's politics yeah
how long did it take before they finally
banned uh fair con off all these social
media platforms
i wasn't following i don't know they got
rid of
all the white nationalists farrakhan was
allowed to stay on
twitter allowed him to say things that
were overtly anti-semitic and he's a
supremacist
uh racial supremacist just happens to be
a difference if you if you took
quotes from farrakhan and in any
instance of the word black you just
swapped out white you'd probably
confuse people because they think it was
hitler because absolutely
yeah and and so i'll say this he should
be allowed to be on twitter he should be
allowed to say what he wants to say good
because when he was saying this stuff we
all saw it and now
when the new york times brings it up we
know it and when we see the suspect
we know what he believed and who he
followed and that's creepy
creepy stuff good to know yeah
absolutely
but think about what happens when they
ban this guy the only reason the new
york times is like
they repeatedly promoted anti-semitism
is because the news stories that erupted
when farrakhan would post these things
or when these videos would come out
you get rid of that speech you get rid
of that you know that ability to share
information
and we'd be wondering like who's
farrakhan i don't know what this
is it was a religious fellow i think
racist should expose themselves
let them talk we'll judge them hold them
accountable but yeah don't ban them from
stuff i want to see what they want to
say
you know i think the issue though is
that these like the ultra woke people
they're the racists you know they and
they do a really good job of
masquerading as
the not racists you know going around
telling everybody that they're
anti-racist they got they got that book
was it anti-racist baby
oh yeah kids books that are being made
and tell the kids how to be a you know
cult member and things like that
well they go around naming their cult
anti-racists and it reminds me of the
simpsons when uh
homer is telling the story about when
he's a kid and they had the no homer's
club
and then he's like but you let in that
other home we're like we're allowed to
have one like they made the name
specifically to address something they
were you know didn't want
anti-racist and then they go around
literally discriminating based on race
and encouraging overt hardcore
unitarianism and anti-semitism
and i'm just like man the the there's so
many well-to-do liberals
that are so obsessed with social justice
narratives they overlook the fact that
black nationalist anti-semites exist in
large numbers
with a massive following and they're
sitting here going like but what about
trump supporters
what about them we're going to wave a
little american flag around i get it the
people at the capitol
there's a decent amount of people that
went crazy and stormed the capital that
was bad
but you compare that to everything we've
seen and the strength of the movement
from things like
uh you know farrakhan it's just not even
a question but that stuff's just
they ignore all that this actually seems
to be a prevalent thing in the
african-american community because if
you look at the attacks
well if you look at the attacks on
jewish people in new york city
uh majority of them are done by a
certain ethnic minority
i know i know i know you can't say it
but you can look at the videos and you
can be like oh my gosh this is like
actually a problem in their community
and i wonder if that is the influence of
um the you know the nation of islam i
don't know
i think that's why the atlanta spa
shooting
got so much outrage because it was a
white dude i think they were secretly
happy that it was a white person to say
oh these white people hate asian people
honestly i've never met a white person
that hates asian people i love asian
people
i wish they would move index to me i
want my kid to go to their schools i
love asian people
i think it could be a problem in the
black community uh i've heard there's
tensions between the agents moving in
and having like stores and like liquor
stores
and convenience stores and they think
they're taking away they're making
profits off the black people
i don't know that's not my community but
i've heard there's tension there
but they want to focus on oh these white
people hate asian people i don't think
that's really a huge
thing it's when you look at the rules
of youtube facebook instagram twitter
etc
etc you're allowed to disparage white
people yeah
yeah like outright like they've even
talked about how i think i can't
remember which platform it was they said
you know you you're allowed to make
disparaging comments
on traditionally non-marginalized groups
of people or whatever like we know what
that means
and so you know thinking back to like
old comedy
it was always safe to be like oh okay
white people you know you have people
crazy
yeah you can make fun of them and i
understand the the the idea behind it
right the left would tell you was like
oh there's white privilege
yeah and because of that you're punching
up which is fine but punching down is
wrong
but that means because of these rules
you can't have very real conversations
that are that are important
you mentioned the gentrification problem
that's
absolutely very prominent within
left-wing activist circles and uh within
black lives matter
for instance and to clarify too what
asian means in many of these communities
is not
like chinese or japanese it's indian as
well it's middle eastern
so when i was in ferguson they burned
down a gas station during the michael
brown riots
and i interviewed some of the people
there why did you burn down this gas
station
they said because the asian guy comes
here
and he buys a gas station in our
neighborhood why is he making money off
of us
he doesn't live here so they burn it
down we broadcast that that was on vice
that's on youtube i mean i don't know if
they still have it up but that's what
they said
so there's very much racial tensions
when i was in milwaukee
during uh black lives matter uh um
rioting
they straight up were yelling get the
white people f the white people
and an 18 year old white kid got shot in
the neck i grew up
watching this stuff and it's no surprise
to me but i'm i'm curious you know
when i mentioned that i did i did a
video saying i wasn't going to be
covering what was going on in milwaukee
at the time because
of the racial tensions and i was like
for someone they perceive to be white
it's dangerous you know this kid got
shot in the neck so i'm i'm not going to
stick around
it's remarkable i did that video because
i think i had like 20 000 subscribers
and there are people who follow me and
they wanted me to post videos from what
was going on on the ground and i said
i'm not going to do it and here's why
and it was just to my followers well the
video ended up going viral and getting
shared by a bunch of conservatives who
are like oh look at this this is
you know proof of something and the left
was like tim poole only did that to
grift
i'm like to who my 20 000 followers who
i know and follow and comment
yeah this is it's crazy yeah you make
money well but
yeah right but it's it's insane how like
these things are real
and these racial tensions exist and
there's
absolutely racism in the black community
in the asian community in in the latino
community in the white community towards
each other as well
oh definitely i mean asians oh my gosh
hispanic people
talk about each other it's just gossip
yeah
yeah but i don't know yeah so i feel
like
there's kind of like i feel like we're
in a cultural uh the left is in a
cultural mexican standoff
yeah where they're all just there's just
like piranhas everywhere these these
culture warriors
ready to cancel you the moment you say
something that's cancelable
so no one will have honest conversations
about their communities or other
communities or racism
because they'll get canceled the moment
they do i hope i get cancelled though
because dr seuss got cancelled and his
books are up
i have children's books i hope i get
canceled so i can go top
yeah on amazon what are your what are
your what are your children's books i
have two children's books
it's a first one is nobody knows how to
make a pizza it's based on littered
reads eye pencil
but i made it for kids about pizza also
it talks about you know division of
labor spontaneous order all those
economic
cools yeah so there's no central planner
making this pizza it's people all over
the world
doing the tomatoes and the cheese yeah
yeah because there's no one person who
grows tomatoes
farms dairy yeah grinds wheat yeah
oregano and then brings it all together
with sugar
it's all different farms and gifts yeah
you think sometimes pizza is really
simple but it's
it's really complicated yeah yeah i
wonder if uh somewhere someone's
actually
decided to make a pizza farm like let me
just make all the things we got cows we
got tomatoes i think you guys could do
it
yeah it's a lot of work for pizza thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you